stop
[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you'll say happy holidays too dude
because just happy holidays your
yeah your Christmas it's about Hanukkah
there's a lot of holidays going on there
are but my the women of my family
whether it's my wife whether it's my ex
whether it's my mom everybody loves
Christmas I love Christmas I mean they
there is music playing oh it starts
around Thanksgiving sir we've had a tree
in our house for a long time you guys do
Elf on the Shelf we sure do pip it's a
beast oh they name it pip they only did
one well I guess you can do one if
you're basic but if you have yeah
usually do one for each kid oh really so
I have a white one and then a a darker
one dark one yeah well listen this my
kids their names are chippy and brownie
chippy and brownie no he's six right so
tiger naming brownie yeah he's sick so
be cool I know it's called brownie based
off the dessert the brownies okay all
right
and that's what he came with that name
or did the family name him he named it
all else matter here bro okay well your
family is half Brown your family is
Mexican big man you have yeah yeah so he
can say brownie so um
yeah it's exhausting yes do it every
night well you have to hide him or you
have to put him somewhere oh you put him
on a shelves clearly your wife does it
right you just toast in yeah I do so
it's a surprise for Brian too yes well I
do all of it so there you have the floor
is lava taped into the wall chin go to
the burrito one then I made him burritos
tonight I'm covered in aluminum foil but
see my kids have to find pip
no they come down
oh you come down with that that's so
good dude you did that oh yeah I do all
this dude there you go yep I like to mix
it up that's very good bro and it keeps
these little bastards in line there you
go
that's so good not gonna lie I'm still
on a few of your ideas this one I'm
definitely going to do my man oh that's
the thing another parent or dad did this
before people get all these ideas like
if you run out of ideas just go to Etsy
or Google elves on the shelf ideas
there's a million of them online yeah
well my kids now are getting older and
when they get older they're like
whatever
well my thing my thing is with Santa
like my girl like wouldn't tell tiger
Santa gone this like the [ __ ] we are
yeah Dad got him this Dad I'm telling
dick jokes on the road for about 40
dates that's not used to any bad words
because we get to monetize well only
first minute okay we passed that are we
yep four minutes in yeah we're good
daddy that's good now uh so I don't I
don't I don't I don't subscribe to Santa
delivered all this no no no no no no no
no no no no no no Santa's right here you
know what Daddy forgot he's in fiction
daddy forgets to buy everybody presents
I mean I forget remember I'm a bad
person bad person I forget
her body present don't you remember
years ago you got me that nice espresso
machine man I wasn't using it and you
just kept pestering me how is it do you
like I'm like you know it was up on a
shelf that's a 600 espresso machine yeah
he's a fine art piece it's art you still
have it no remembers because they took
it to Stevie but you would not leave me
alone about it when you give a gift Let
It Go well it was a little too expensive
for you to have it sit there yeah it was
but at the time you know coffee I could
have used it now you could use it now a
little more educated out you got the
fills going on and I don't know if
that's just opened in Calabasas what is
that though that's very very tasty I
think this is the Wonder Bar with a
scoop of mocha see this is the our boy
Tarik azim special well Tark knows his
stuff yeah and I've never got anything
different there Phil's Coffee just
opened up across the street from us wow
well I think today was the first day I
went you can get some business you're
gonna get some business you need some
business from your boy here I'm all over
that now I want to start saying things
about my boy Brandon Schaub apparently
uh eight inches you've been you well
besides that I'm see you with Thor
apparently Brendan uh and I've said this
about you before but Brandon's a little
stronger than most people think
I don't know if you know this but I'm
gonna go through it I'm gonna go through
it now he took 225 pounds he deadlifted
it how many times sir I almost said 60.
40 and 60 seconds 40 in 60 seconds watch
now I've been dead lifted and this is
[ __ ] second that's good
I can't believe you left that easily
look at this [ __ ] watch this it's only
225. by the way what mistake they admit
is oh we got a lot of people watching
shops are watching shop shop gonna be
usually 20 you'd be like I'm done 100
not when you got a lot of people oh you
don't let me go out you know what my
brain said it's showtime look at how
good this is you know what my brain said
hey
I know you have been dead lifted in
three months and you haven't been in a
gym two months you know what daddy show
time that's where you see how strong you
are though that's [ __ ] do you know
how hard that is what's she doing there
135 she's strong too oh she was like
across it there's big four watching me
but you're dealing with really real
CrossFit people here right Daddy's back
we'll we'll CrossFit she's a little
badass she's a badass wow yeah Kira
here's but then she's a badass but then
my partner was Justin manderos I don't
know if you know Justin Maderos is the
number one Crosser crossfitter in the
world number one number one he's a freak
now let me take him in now I was
unfamiliar with him before I met him and
when they
when they partnered me up with them I
went what's he doing oh uh he's like a
crossfit guy and the rain guy Braden
looks Amigos excuse me he's Crossing he
goes he's the CrossFit I go what's that
mean he goes he's the number one in the
world dude I'm not sure about him I'm
gonna say something about him such a
he's like he's 23. he's much he's he's
much less muscled and not as quite as
thick as a lot of the guys okay like
Matt Frazier and stuff he's thick but
he's
he's uh that's his girl in the
background from Australia she's also a
badass yeah qualified for the CrossFit
Games I think she finished there's
something qualified and she's only doing
for five years qualified I think two or
three times he's a freak how tall is he
not that tall no he's about to feel the
picture eight maybe uh yeah but you know
what his background is I don't wrestling
he was a high school I could have called
it right high school went to Boise State
to wrestle yeah they got rid of the
wrestling program he's like I need
something to do someone said check out
this CrossFit thing he said oh I'll try
it yeah and now he's the best in the
world yes nice kid in the world now he
won 21 and the 20 22. that's so [ __ ]
nuts lives in boys with his girl from
Australia both sweethearts and they
don't know what the event's going to be
until they get there just much like the
strong man so you're talking about now
is the strength in his mullet and if he
trimmed his mullet what would happen
that's what I
said do you think all the power comes
from your mullet but just a sweet sweet
and young but you see him there and
you'd never think that he's what he is
like he looks like he's kind of a you
know but don't judge a book by its cover
he's in clothes and he looks now I was
with him I was with the Another World's
Strongest Man guy I think his profile's
like to get if you go the deadlift when
he's on there well I have a question
he's the first guy you did that 40 times
how many times did Justin do it uh I
think 56 or 50 okay now that's his job
the world's strongest gay yeah that's
him so that's it so he did it too but
that's his that's his job okay this guy
was great too
it was great he's very he's very proud
yeah he was on Rogan for he's he's a
really good dude I'm sure he is dude
strong uh yeah now yeah let me see him I
want to see that guy
you're just on his profile too
hey no this isn't he's not Olympian uh
yeah
so so but he does but so for instance
you know man it's a very rare I'm
surprised oh well Olympia posted my
picture it's very rare I'm surprised by
like you know whenever I see someone
like he's not that big yeah I was like
oh well what's the biggest human being
I've ever seen in my life yes now what
is he lifting there he doesn't look like
755. he doesn't look like your typical
strong man that's look at that he did
have the record
look at how strong he is now I'm gonna
go to another guy where you're going to
jack off to him later go to Juju mufu
it's right it's right there Chen it says
just dead lifting more than PR this dude
jacked City I love that guy he is so
jacked he's and he can do the splits he
says he's such a good time did you meet
him yeah we're all hanging out please he
seems like he's great we're all ready
we're all rain family dude he's so
jacked yeah he's a freak such a fun guy
look at this
now now he was a hit at the Olympia oh
my God I didn't realize how big of a
deal he is you know I'm not in that
world he's
and then his food here's Brian Shaw he's
a hula hooping I don't want to see him
do that but uh his food you know because
it would be long days yeah he had this
he had his luggage with him be he was
just uh carried right you got to turn
the opportunity
podcast I've been following but he so he
has his luggage yeah
gets it out Tupperware up this big
all brown and white rice on top
underneath just a smorgasbord of fish
yams and fish and then just ground grass
coffee yeah just whatever mush just mush
yeah and then everyone's freaking out
because we were we had a long day we
drove Baja trucks we'd like compete in
Baja trucks like jumping over the truck
so much fun wow so we didn't eat and
then he brought his food and then uh
everyone was hungry because it was like
almost noon he's like I'm fine gets it
out and they're like hey we're so sorry
I'm fine and I go what's your philosophy
I mean he goes to me it's just calories
at the end of the week because I don't
count calories during the day it's just
as long as they get by the end of the
week I don't care if I eat at nine in
the morning nine at night so honestly by
the end of the week I get this amount of
calories I don't care oh my God but what
does juju do does he is he a
professional strong man or just a
personality he he did compete and then
now he's just uh you know he's like the
Personality yeah like millions of
followers well he's also crazy [ __ ] such
as personality and smart oh yeah human
being oh yeah all right let's take a
little break Brian Wonder go drain the
snake so your boys left to do it it's
that time of the year everyone's excited
about gifts the holiday spirit but what
all you guys should be excited about is
basketball that's right the NBA is here
and get in on the action with my friends
at DraftKings Sportsbook and official
sports betting part of the NBA new
customers can bet just five dollars per
game money line on any NBA team to win
their game and get 150 in free bets if
they do plus everyone can combine
multiple bets for a bigger payout with
DraftKings same game parlays I want you
to take my nugs jokic Ballin again the
Lakers bro I don't bet on them all right
Maryland sports fans listen up draftking
Sportsbook is live in your state in
holler Maryland get you some you're
welcome download the app right now to
get in on the holiday Hoops Action Sign
up with the code fighter plays a five
dollar pregame moneyline bet on any NBA
team to win and get 150 in free bets if
they do only a draftking Sportsbook with
Road fighter and you can bet on NBA
basketball college bowl games you got
MMA UFC they got it all DraftKings
minimum age eligibility restrictions
apply C show notes for details draftking
Sportsbook code fighter
this episode of the fight on the kid is
brought to you by Rogue nicotine my
friends at Rogue nicotine if you're a
regular viewer of firing the kid or any
show that I do which I do way too many
podcasts you're gonna recognize one
thing and one thing only on every single
set it's Rogue nicotine that's right I
have my cans everywhere they're hidden
this time boom right behind the Rogue
sign baby I take them everywhere right
now I'm sipping on that mango that's
right six milligrams they offer three or
six but they have all sorts of flavors
I'm talking Berry they got Wintergreen
peppermint honey lemon apples my hands
down all-time favorite the Rogue flavor
destroys anything out there that's why I
joined the team all right again you're
getting three or six milligrams but you
know I stay on them six Millies dog I
stay on them and Beyond pouches Rogue
also makes other great nicotine products
if you don't want pouches they have gum
tablets lozengers they got it all I'm a
pouch guy all right but I'll switch it
up from time to time I usually stay on
the six Milli pack uh pouches all right
I take them anywhere I want flights
airport green rooms comedy clubs podcast
Studios without any restrictions Rogue
is my go-to source for nicotine for
everything I'm such a fan of Rogue I
asked to be part of all my shows so here
we are it's my favorite if you want to
try Rogue pouches like your boy here
we're gonna try the gums or tablets
however you get your nicotine go to
roguenixteen.com use the code rogue20
that's r-o-g-u-e-20 for 25 your entire
order again Rogue 20 for 20 off your
order it's the best of the best it's the
best nicotine on the planet I'm talking
about Rogue daddy Rogue nicotine under
eight sales prohibited warning the
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical for more information
visit Rogue nicotine.com now let's get
back to the program well he's got a
sense of humor 1.6 million that's what I
love about it so let's get him on the
podcast he said funny silly goose
did you love this beat so that he's
trying to eat and he's like trying to
get the calories in and this guy who's
not reading the room comes up to him and
he's like ask him all these questions
and he's like yeah you're trying to eat
he goes do you like
I think it was like uh it's some sort of
beat or something yeah what leaks yeah
you like leaks
and even I looked up I was eating I'm
like what did you like leaks and he just
stares at him goes
I don't have opinion on those
and in my head in my head I was like
perfect answer my first reaction was
yeah that's kind of a dick move and I
thought what a brilliant answer yeah and
then he explained he goes I don't have
opinion on those there you go so yeah he
goes I've never had them so I have an
opinion on it and then the guy leaves
and I was like God read the room to you
like I know and I go man what a powerful
answer I don't have an opinion and he
started laughing I go at first I was
taken back but I thought my God I knew
you more like that yeah because if you
would ask me I've never tried them
either I would have told him something
yeah it's my job to create nothing out
of something man like I gotta get well
my favorite so I just goes I don't have
an opinion that's that's like uh uh my
Dad's friend very very successful man
and uh somebody he was in the public eye
and somebody said this guy was very
critical of him like some journalist or
something what do you think of such and
such and he goes why would I ever want
to think about him and it was a great
answer yeah you know like just moving on
whoa yeah you know I don't have an
opinion on that oh my God I need to
implement that more in my life yeah not
mean which is like an opinion I've never
had it yeah okay Moving On Moving On
Moving on oh dude you love this though
Thor so we have to do this uh you had to
do a tractor uh a trailer pull you
pulled the truck no truck not a tractor
pulled a truck truck
and and uh your boy was icy cold too I
was worried about my hand you know I'm
having hamstring yeah so I was worried
about blowing them out so you just
wrapped it on and pulled on pulled how
did you do it in jokes as I'm pulling
too I'm the only one who's not
professional athlete okay I'm gonna get
in some sticky I'm gonna get some some
sick his sticky subjects don't throw
them under the bus now I'm gonna get
into my friends I'm going to ask
simple keep the same energy kept with
your boy Brian Shaw I'm gonna ask and
simple questions I'm not even going to
ask simple questions I'm going to make a
couple statements and then you can say I
don't have an opinion on that that's all
we're talking about okay now did you or
did you not pull
the truck yes how did you do in
comparison to the people that were
professional that do it for a living
like Thor finish right behind him third
third place
how many by a minute oh no minute Jesus
no a few seconds a few seconds
few seconds
you now remember this is Thor this store
at 3 30 when he's competing is over 400.
I understand but 330 is a lot and um and
then you also deadlifted with the number
one crossfitter yes he beat you by 13.
and you don't do that
Thor beat me by two
by two yeah I think he did two 65 out of
225. he did 42. that's significant yeah
all right so
my only question is this
eight ounces
well
you're you you don't are you taking any
you take nicotine
a lot of nicotine a lot of caffeine a
lot of caffeine multivitamin you drink
diet coke ag1
um maybe some Alpha Brain magic mind
magic mind we're big fans of magic mine
so you're you're we're always fueled by
Magic I'm gonna test positive for all
those things yeah I don't have my I
didn't get my magic mind today do we
have any magic mine I don't know gotta
ask our boy I don't think we do
by the way we're not paid for that yeah
we're not sponsored by Magic mine yet we
take it because we're obsessed with it
um keep going though
but
how much
testosterone human growth and synthetic
hormones do you shoot in your ass that's
all I'm asking it's a question that I'm
asking you
I don't have an opinion on that
but some would say you're probably not
doing any of that
no okay you're not doing any of that
what's your point Brian my point is only
that you're uh you know what everybody
tests positive for and I can confirm
this positive attitudes positive
attitude of course that's again being
strong positive attitude having ass
wet lips wet lips and full of rain body
fuel okay okay there's body fuel I know
where you're going with this body fuel
I'm not saying anything I was asking to
make sure if you're all natural because
I know I'm sure that the that the rest
of the playing field in all of these
kinds of strength competitions are
fairly
natural too I don't see needles
I I don't I only see color I don't see
needles oh I'm that then that's all I
want to see personalities it's just that
it does beg the question
well if I took Brandon's job and I said
we got to get serious I need a year of
training and I'm gonna juice you the
[ __ ] up oh dude my feeling is daddy's
gonna daddy's gonna move daddy's gonna
do all right scary I blow his dick off
but I'm gonna do all right well you're
gonna you could probably move some scary
weight and you also have better
endurance than a lot of people now the
other thing too is you realize Thor's an
absolute competitor because we're like
shooting the scene the commercial doing
deadlifts and he had all the weights he
was like deadlifting 800 face wasn't
even making it's interesting 800 and
just steam warm up just doing it freak
and I was making I was like hey save
some weights for me am I right like
stupid jokes and then uh I go over there
and we're talking about what's the most
you've done I said uh
as I did 600 last summer and he goes
that's that's good for you man
especially for me okay uh and then he
goes I go but football it's just
different we don't really Max up to that
extent you know our thing's 225. he goes
oh yeah you guys do 225 with the combine
protein would do 225 ago you ever done
225 yeah so much you did he goes uh I
think he said a few months ago I did 40.
I think maybe 36. oh cool you're
supposed to do that uh last summer I did
40.
and his face changing us you beat me I
go I guess I mean dude no you get that
your answer is well you have longer arms
no I was like you know you're so much
heavier it's not a big deal but you know
right so I'm so much lighter but the
thing is is I said it's it's a
conditioning it's a rep thing I was
training for it and I said now at the
combine with the count all those reps I
wasn't fully extended he goes well I was
fully extended yeah so you're probably
better but I did 40. no matter what you
said at 40. he goes cool do it now we'll
film it I'll me and you go we'll do it
now he's got competitive yeah I went I'm
not doing that now I go dude I just got
done deadlifting pulling a truck I'm not
gonna do it now anyways no do it now yo
so I'm not doing it now and then I have
to get Sterling Thor game games of
thrones Thorne right not happening games
of Thor it's not happening and he goes
okay that's fine oh yeah dude you're
We're not gonna do this this is stupid
dude I think it was all right tomorrow
morning meet me here we'll do it I went
all right dude I got his face we're
friends at this point his face you loved
him right he's a great I absolutely fell
in love with him I got his face I went
Thor I can't emphasize enough I don't
give a [ __ ] how strong you are and I'm
not gonna meet you here tomorrow you
started laughing dude I don't do any of
this anymore I said I don't care I want
to meet him he sounds great we gotta get
him on the podcast but they kept asking
me questions uh like he had his crew as
film crew who's great and so I was
making them laugh and then we're going
back and forth and they were asking me
fight questions and then you go you get
you you if we ask you anything up
outside fighting get kind of you know
it's so much fun then we talk about
finding it's kind of short I do it for a
living man it's also you know I said
Thor
do you like when people ask about Game
of Thrones how long was that he was out
like eight ten years ago exactly dude I
said I said also Game of Thrones his
real name is Thor Thor yeah yeah Thor
Hanson Iceland yeah but he was saying
Game of Thrones like when he went to
like Comic Con stuff like that you know
he was people are such rabbit fans and
they read the books and he's like
they're asking about like oh the the
Lannister family bloodline he's like ah
I don't [ __ ] know what you're talking
about man
I said I said so here's what we'll do
Thor for you and I moved forward in our
relationship I think because we have a
time share together this is what we're
going to do every time you ask me a
fight question I'm gonna ask you a Game
of Thrones question let's see how many
questions are asked go you start well
fighting is interesting to a guy like
that because he does a little bit of it
Game of Thrones is interesting to me
yeah you know what he said about
fighting though you like what because I
was asking him like you I was like
you're similar to me where you you're
outside the box strong man acting boxing
like what's next he's like ah he's like
I would I I don't wanna I'm gonna
announce it because I do have something
coming up but I can't announce it here
not that much smaller than me I promise
you it's not even close no I know we're
sitting down it's not he's
the biggest human being I've ever seen
Sports yeah so big his calves were this
[ __ ] big his wife this big he's a
true this big she's tiny Savage yeah I'm
impressed with her but so so keep going
so uh where was I what was I talking
about uh I'm sorry I was looking at that
Jen you gotta not Brian can't do both
all right no no but but but but
um you were saying uh fighting he said I
like this about oh oh and he was saying
because I said you boxed right because
you boxed um uh uh no no
um and he beat Eddie and I said you
wanna do more boxing now there's more
money you know Jake Paul would never
fight but something like that and he's
like I hated it because I hated every
moment of it he goes I hated the
training I'd wake up hated it the camp I
[ __ ] hated it he was the the road
work I hated training practicing
sparring hated it if I hated it he said
never do it again he just takes a
special kind of person well here's what
I really admire about a guy like Thor
and and anybody like this you got to
remember like yeah he's a giant and
stuff he was still the strongest man in
the world he still competed against like
some badass dudes and and it and you
know you have to be so competitive and
you have to be so good at that well I
saw it I saw his switch turn on when I
tell him oh yeah when he challenged with
225 I went interesting oh yeah and then
he's been successful well in a lot of
different fields and everything that's
what me and him were talking about on
the show like we both had success I mean
all of it that's what we're talking
about that's not a mistake no it's not
an accident it's his work ethic and he's
a smart guy so know that's by mistake so
we're comparing my career to hear it's
going back and forth about it I said
yeah you and I don't stay in the lane
like we don't subscribe to how
everyone's like well you got to do this
like right try other stuff and he goes
oh he goes oh yeah he showed me a video
on his phone he was oh last night I went
to the pi and stood at UFC and I rolled
with Gordon Ryan
and he goes you want to see it I go no I
know how it went it's what you mean I
don't need to see it he taught you a
knot it was dude I he's like I thought
because I was a bigger guy you know I've
rolled a little bit I thought I could do
something I go it's insane dude he's
literally the best we have to offer and
he's not that small compared to you
might be small but he's not that slowly
strong I said that's his language and he
goes he goes I can be honest because I
know I was ignorant he was I thought I'd
do better he was he was literally
tossing me in the air flipping me
sweeping me choked me whenever he wanted
he goes I couldn't believe it I go there
were so many people need to roll just a
normal black belt yeah to understand
what level you have to get to be a black
belt I said now you decide to roll with
the one percent of one percent or black
belt yeah he's the best to ever do it
he's like really I'm like the best the
last time I rolled with a black belt was
um Nico who was Sam triple his friend my
friend and he he's my size maybe even a
little skin doesn't matter black belt
when I tell you
tapping me but he kept using a doors
from different angles and I couldn't
stop it of course I was like you but why
would you know but I'm like what the
[ __ ] why would you be able to one like
one to the top one that's like being
pissed you can't speak uh uh Farsi of
course of course and you're reading from
the Farsi Bible and you're like I don't
understand how I can't do it what do you
mean I'm right what do you mean you
thought you were gonna do well and
you're not doing anything you're not you
can try to stop whatever you want it
ain't happening I thought Thor goes I he
was like all right he rolled me and goes
again again he was finally I was like
I'm just not gonna do anything I'm just
gonna try and hold him down just
couldn't it I go Thor he he is
I told though I go you have a better
chance at blocking Kevin Durant's shot
yeah than having any success against
Gordon Ryan it's not happening I can't
believe that you're gonna do well I
couldn't stop laughing which he did not
enjoy oh really I couldn't stop laughing
because he kept going I he actually did
he actually think he'd have a chance he
thought you who he was like I know I
wouldn't beat him but I thought I could
at least you know at least control him a
little bit no no no well that was like
with Bradley Martin and and as athletic
and strong as he is but he dabbles in
Jiu Jitsu I was like if you roll with
Dylan Dennis or one of those guys like
and you were like try it I could see
that I was like that wouldn't that's not
good that's all I do I don't I don't get
in the debate a lot of picking up some
Google try it go ahead go take a world
champion like John Dennis I know I know
oh he's a clown on social media no I get
all that that's fun roll them roll that
I mean how it goes for you
exactly like it went for Thor but what
you want to talk about uh like because
they they broke it up into groups so
they do like waves so I was the first
seat and there was a second he first he
was like me the CrossFit uh champ Justin
uh uh juji
um and then the power lifter the gay
power lifter that was like the first
seat but the second heat was you know
you're going to be working out like this
I have no clue and I signed autographs
for four hours before this oh my back is
already tight I'm I'm fine right now
though but um
the second heat when they started
walking up I was like oh now the real
celebrities are here now that juji I
didn't realize that he was doing his
line was insane yeah when Thor and Eva
Eva Marie I think the WWE girl she's
she's probably on the post for a rain
she's a pink hair gorgeous you know
she's gorgeous she's like the villain
WWE I know she is
straight up dying piece but so she's
super famous among that crowd Thor
obviously is super famous their shoes
yeah she's she's she's
what's the word oh yeah chords oh I
asked not to be next to her I was like
are we the same species
yeah she's uh well that's awesome too
and her and her husband were there like
such shoes who's our hubby her husband
that's her right there yeah that's her
husband right that's right there that's
that's uh
you know what got good for that normal
looking guy good for that normal looking
fella but I was telling they just moved
to uh Dallas but uh look at her hair is
so cool but I was um he's so lucky but
um he's so lucky but so lucky
um I was uh talking to her about
and and she didn't comment on this I'm
not trying to get in trouble with the
WWE but I said when you're negotiating
contracts because it's not like the UFC
like if Sean Strickland or Connor or Jon
Jones decide they want to be the heel
and be the dark person you know they win
fights it's very black and white but in
WWE it's they decide who's gonna be a
star who's gonna be the heel but if they
decide your heel well especially in
social media time people are stupid and
think that's actually you so the amount
of toxic negative comments you're gonna
get on social media down the road you're
not getting as many sponsorships as the
baby face now or the champion do they
take that in consideration when they uh
negotiate your contractures I don't
think I've ever heard anybody bring that
up
I went oh you know when it comes to
fighter pay I have to dive into that so
I was just thinking WWE and she went
very good question yeah and then she she
was like no comment there's no cameras
around sure no comments yeah she's like
that's a brilliant idea though yeah I'm
like because you gotta realize in 22
when they go you're gonna be the heel
the fan base goes that's a bad person
[ __ ] them and they attack you online so
she gets death threats her family's
death threats her husband get smart
people out there some smart people real
smart because they think it's real
that'd be like being mad at
um The Joker in a movie yeah instead of
desperate it's like you you're a bad
person Joker excuse me so you know so
the fan base doesn't realize it that she
was it was planned for her to be the bad
person so she didn't get so much
backlash online you're not getting the
big endorsements like Pepsi or Coke or
whatever it's not gonna co-sign this
villain so they should compensate you
more yeah she was like no comment
but I can see the wheels turning I like
to plant that little seat I'm gonna walk
away now that must have been pretty cool
and some of those CrossFit women have
got
um cakes
I mean you didn't there wasn't a flat
ass to be found bro it's not asking oh
you know me and women
my ass isn't bad no no my ass isn't
terrible
there I've never wrote I've never
thought about your oh no there I was Mr
Burns my ass was yeah so bring up Miss
Burns Ashton last was
that's my ass at the Olympia dude it's
amazing they almost they almost yeah
they almost didn't let me in yeah I know
they're like oh man well well usually
don't let flat asses in yeah those
CrossFit gals are no it's not even the
crowd because Olympia is not really
there's something Olympia's bodybuilders
oh okay and then the bodybuilder girls
yeah they devlift and do them squats so
that ass has to grow no it's it's a
fertilizer troll they're fertilized it's
out of control my neck and by the way
your ass is part of your what you're
showing off so you you're working your
glue and they're not wearing loose
clothes either guys or gals everybody
got an ass real fake it's fantastic it's
a whole situation oh
oh wow yeah
oh boy I've never seen so many dudes
look like cardi B from behind it was
just and you know I was that real right
there oh that's right dude you love that
dude I was trying not to look so my neck
my neck's [ __ ] up because I wasn't I
wasn't looking B I was going like this
trying to avoid it but I'd look over her
ass ass ass ass yep it's very difficult
it'll actually exhaust you it'll exhaust
you when you gotta look that much it
gets in your you know you're just like
ah oh you know what you know what
exhausts me is by no means am I as
famous as Thor so many people are coming
up to him I just started trolling his
pictures I just started photo bombing
his pictures once I ran on my fans I
looked at his line I'm like use on Game
of Thrones the background going I'm
going like this yep and there's camera
gambling you believe this he's crazy
he's crazy famous guys stupid famous
that's why he lives in Iceland I was
talking about he's famous is our
CrossFit boy he's famous among the
crossfitters CrossFit he's he's he's
he's Patrick Mahomes yeah he's the guy
he's young his personality his girl is
pretty famous too from Australia so you
know probably half a million followers
on social media but it's not all about
social who's that girl she's a CrossFit
or that guy she was the most uh
successful female American of all time
she just retired she's 30. wow what is
her name Cara Pierce Cara Terry Pierce
there's a LED Turner that's that's his
uh that's Justin's girlfriend okay
oh there it is
that's not his girlfriend the shoe's the
retired one though she's tired
six-time CrossFit athlete game four-time
Fitness
she's a crazy she's in crazy [ __ ] she
did 135 she got like 50 some I mean
insane she's 30. yeah 30 31. huh
really that's all they do dude yeah
they're they're freaks no oh freaks
pretty sure she's 30 31. the strain of
the it's a lot of work
she looks a little bit a little bit
older than that that's fine I'm 33 33
yeah yeah it's just that you put your
body through a lot like I guess that's
the time to retire you know yeah I mean
oh go back go back go back that's where
she was let me see
go go up that's not Herbie that's her
helping people out no that's her that's
not that's not no it's not that's a
difference it's a client for God's sakes
all right you know what I'm saying like
she's just giving them she knows a lot
that's if you want to train somebody
that's the gal right there she probably
knows
freaks dude yeah they're just different
athletes they're just beasties you gotta
just put yourself through crazy about
that Olympia and I don't follow Olympia
really anymore but the the Remy's like
the guy who won it I assume Remy did but
it's not like remember we used to
thought when it was like Phil Heath uh
Kai I was with Kai Greene all weekend
he's awesome Kai Greene stayed relevant
for a long time amazing he was a real is
he still training oh he's still
competing jacked he's still competing no
no no oh is that right Hattie trooping
um the first Iranian competitor to ever
take
so
um yeah collection who like do they have
the like the results like first second
third or which we had a computer we do
here we go
so he did he's the one-on-one how do you
how did you Todd dog get your dick out
of our face hottie so big big Romy
finished fifth only got 30 G's who's Big
Romy he he was uh so big Ryan was
looking to become the eighth person I
don't know I had a list there eighth
person ever to win three Mr Olympic
tiles with six others winning at least
three in a row and then he lost so keep
going down so this is the winner right
there
look at that yeah you know where he's
from Iran all daddy probably all Natty I
would imagine
I want to see the other guys though
you're gonna see more chocolate bodies
in your life either at the Olympia yeah
all chocolate bodies yeah you got a tan
I can't believe we haven't canceled
chocolate body yet you do like food
coloring or whatever it is I don't know
no you just you just it's like a it's a
tanning thing this is Derek Lunsford
and what what I think it was like second
yeah it's such a science to get and
who's Nick Walker just that basic white
boy from Ohio it sounds like maybe now
now um I noticed you're wearing I'm
gonna switch gears here a little bit
because oh there he is oh wow yeah whoa
wait that is that Nick the mutant look
at the one with his back Jen
that's a Photoshop that's not real real
there it is I mean a lot of these look
photoshopped actually
but this looks real
chocolate body white face
vanilla face chocolate body
looking good boys
ah those legs are uh ridiculous
built like a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
yeah that's a crazy body now um
chocolate let's let's switch gears a
little bit you're wearing an Argentina
fan I don't know if you know this I've
been a die-hard Argentina it's crazy to
say that since since 1983 it's been my
team for me they've been my team since
they won and I have to say me too that
uh name another player not named Messi
yeah and I'm glad you I'm glad you asked
me that question you know what I say
Diaz some one of those guys anyway yeah
and I I it's one of those guys dude it's
a team effort I'm not gonna single
anybody out okay
Sergio
there you go Sergio just great uh look
I'm a die hard Argentina fan I'm a
die-hard messy fan my favorite food
that's all no bro look at my shirt I've
had this since the baby that was that
was a crazy something exciting something
that was such an exciting and my dad got
me double X they knew down the road I
would appreciate it and 78 I like born
83. I like it dude and you were that
size now here's the thing
um
whatever his name from uh France another
freak he won the Golden Boot he won the
gold now you know Messi mbappe and uh
needlemeyer yeah are all teammates
those
yeah okay 90 million 90 million yeah
he's 23. now be cool he's 498 feel old
yes 23. such a freak
yeah so that so that pair of Saint
Germain messy plays on there he plays
they're on the same team I didn't know
and uh niedermeyer I think I know I
messed his name I think it's Nehemiah we
got the Brazilian so the three stars
they all play the same thing oh Neymar
Neymar oh Anita Mart dude
I'm such a big fan no in Portuguese
Portuguese all right neither mind of
course neither mind a Paris
Saint-Germain football club I didn't
realize well listen I mean they all play
on that team so why they're on the map
considered like a lot of people say I
was talking to a guy who was yesterday
who is the uh broadcaster and played for
each broadcaster for 18 years uh for the
World Cup played for 18 years wait he
was broadcasting the World Cup and he
called you after the cup what's that I'm
gonna have a hard time buying this no he
got done with the broadcast finals but
he was like Brian I have to talk he
didn't call the finals he called most of
the the World Cup but not the finals no
and I said it's his name I don't
remember his name but he played for 18
years I'm not buying this at all go go
and he called you
he's English there he is JP this guy
really no
keep going I'm calling [ __ ] Derek
I'll find him
keep going that's it these here yeah
back up hold on Eric Ray
no that's not him all right I'll find
him Andreas [ __ ]
um
you think maybe as a soccer podcast no
no no hold on right it does it in the
basement sir right sir does he play FIFA
a lot sir he's there he's did he win the
World Cup in FIFA buddy let me see where
where are the oh Fernando is that him uh
with the stash
yeah he's there
anyway it's gone it's guy malbrand go
ahead Carry On Let's Pretend This is
legit and he said uh yeah I'm probably
as him it's a British one just look up
English it says worked on BBC so it is
BBC World Cup
BT Sport yeah yeah well one of those
[ __ ] guys sure maybe it's Clive yep
let me see either way it never happened
but let's pretend it did carry on bring
up no it's definitely not Clive
it's that guy right there Gary lineker
oh there he is okay Carry On so he uh he
I said what is if you had your choice
Pele Maradona messy Ronaldo you get one
pick nothing he said I think Messi is
Magic he said I think messiest does
things that I think no one ultimately
has done like he's that good General
General answer
back it up nobody said like others are
like guys on his level played that long
they'll look at him they go like you can
see that like Ronaldo's such a freak
athlete and all that but Messi's five
six and they just he's a freak though
whatever that was nuts he's a freak
athlete too don't get twisted super
freak but I I think those guys are all
freak athletes like whatever it is about
them well you know but you know Messi
and Ronaldo when they're like four yeah
they found them and then they were
grooming them to get to the big leagues
so yeah
it's it's being able to see the field
being able to place the ball where it
needs to be it's you got everything I
got one buddy in his son plays soccer
and his it's not Saint Germain it's
another Premier League team he's the
Scout he's at dinner with him he's like
man look at my son what do you think
because they see it early and goes
he's trying to be nice
looks like something fun that's it yeah
it looks like something fun and then you
go so do you see anything else no no no
he goes he's six he goes I know looks
like he's having fun are you done now
that's six he's like say something fun
in America okay wow if you want to show
me a Brazilian kid in the favelas who's
six yeah it's gonna hurt your feelings
It's Gonna Hurt looks like he's having
fun so I get back to dinner there's a
guy who played who's a stupid [ __ ] yes
there's a guy who played for Cameroon or
something or doesn't matter or somewhere
was was a high level baller but you see
him he's coaching all the little kids
you see him he's uh I don't know six two
and thin but you can see he's just a
straight up athlete you know he looks
different sure his kid
he had a child with a Swedish woman or
something who's also an athlete tall
drink of water you see his kid
with those other kids outlier and it's
it's so obvious you're like that kid
looks like he's on Spring oh but it
looks like he's on a trampoline when he
runs dude I keep it real with my kid
tiger he's six he his his buddy uh
Joshua plays with the you know the 10
and 12 year olds because he's such a
freak his dad he Stakes too but he can't
play the 10 and 12 year old oh the first
game I said man I wish we had Josh right
here in the coach looked through his
he'd scored 50 goals he can't be out
here what because this is for like entry
level what he can't be out of his little
score 50 goals we get you shut the
league down he's that good he goes that
kid's an outlier why does his dad played
Pro and he grew up doing it and doing
all the footwork
and he loves it right passionate about
plays six times a week not those like
you can't hang out with tiger kids
playing soccer so Tiger's like oh my
buddy wants to play I'm gonna play
Charlie's playing I go the games he only
scores a goals first game on Google when
the hot tub that night go I'm finding us
yeah soccer's not for you right see what
you mean this thing will be your thing
he was no doubt I get fun right but it's
not your thing and then he has already
how do you use nice things he's gonna be
too big and just the foot where all that
he's gonna be too too big if you want to
be a goalie yeah be a football player
football player and then uh he played uh
that Daddy couldn't be you're too big no
yeah 270. also in America right hey
I don't know it's coming we're getting
there we're getting it they came out the
rankings and America's ranked 15th yeah
but I got a problem with that because we
are because they're not American they're
all for [ __ ] Europe but then they're
no there's a lot of Americans
there's a ton of English isn't their
first language let's put it down no they
are it'll be a hater it's not true yeah
yeah yeah like uh what's his name uh
American team the our best player is is
was born in [ __ ] like Cleveland a lot
of the a lot but he's up Croatian
descent yeah but parents born right
there he's born right there teamwork
played I think duke or some [ __ ] like
that uh polsic Bria Paul sick he's he's
a captain of the team he he he plays for
Liverpool he's a [ __ ] stud dude and
he's from Hershey Pennsylvania bro all
right how dare you place for Chelsea
yeah he's born and raised there man all
right
Superstar
he's the best player on our team by far
and he can play with the boys over in
Premier League most Americans can't yeah
that's not yeah well that's also because
there's a soccer pipeline a program when
you're a kid you go away to soccer
school we do that here too but now you
do not like the way the Europeans well
no now we're getting there but then also
like I'm telling you watch when America
focuses on which we're going to now and
I think because America did have a good
showing right they they went to draw
with England which is massive yes so now
kids are growing up watching that
they're going to be more kind of they're
gonna have more heroes in it pulse uh
you know all the kids are looking up to
him so as kids move on if there's actual
you know something there because think
about we do that in football yeah little
league and then baseball like that's why
we dominate basketball yeah like those
feeder leagues for young kids are nuts
they're playing year round they start
doing that in soccer it could get there
this game was so amazing all everyone
talking about Argentina team let me see
nobody speaks English nobody they're all
dude I'm sick of you being a goddamn
communist every little is from
Pennsylvania yeah one guy speaks English
the rest of them are and he's the best
personally Dutch African no no wow I see
a black guy African huh wow wow wow
that's where we're going child there are
Americans just like you you son of a
[ __ ] yeah your family's from Italy so
if you're on the team would say oh he's
Italian no no I'm just saying you
[ __ ] communist I'm just saying let me
see watch this Sean Jones his name's
Sean Johnson Matt Turner okay Ethan
Sergio death I'll give you back more
Aaron long Shaq Tim Sergio desk you got
a Tim on the team team ready for the
widest thing ever
Tony Robinson Walker Zimmerman okay
DeAndre edlin all right well okay well
Lucha De la Torre I don't know okay I'll
give you the Tyler Adams I don't know
Kellen Winston Carolina Costa Acosta
Brendan you you Eunice Musa Jesus Musa
these people are off and there's
Christian pulsik
Beastie you need to educate yourself oh
you're one of those guys you're one of
those guys Christian you gotta we gotta
get rid of those bangs now uh we makes
all the money in the world so yeah
definitely fix your hair but um and also
Tim
I feel like you'd be a good Receiver
right because to look for it tip away
yeah that Tim Brown Tim always got some
speech Josh Sergeant now now um hey you
that guy World Cup what's it's the thing
right now so you dip your toe in it yeah
dude perfect since 1978 fair weather fan
it is exciting though at that level I
love it well you only love it hey we're
all excited about the soccer right now
food to ball for the rest of you
yeah once every four years worth and I
missed hey once every four years yes and
I missed a lot too many games I missed
Brazil losing I watched all of them I
saw most of them is my girl so into it
but dude but she makes me watch it with
the Mexican commentating to make it even
worse it's more exciting though it's not
because you don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying now there was a video of
the Argentinian
um broadcaster he's been doing it for 30
years this was his last game when he
goes when they win I get chills he goes
go you know how they go and starts
crying go go and he's trying to get it
out dude it's powerful hold on
that's the coach
dude they were so emotional it was so
beautiful
announcer is it Andres Contour yeah
I gotta see this I was I was you know
here
well I don't know go ahead
[Applause]
you can hear the emotion
[Applause]
have you seen when Salt Bay because he's
Argentinian rushes the field and tries
to get Messi's attention it's on
Barstool Instagram I think or Twitter
picture of that guy doing it like
screaming like that no there's no video
just that audio that was [ __ ] good
isn't that crazy that was great that
makes your day wait what is this problem
um so salt-based Argentinian right he's
kind of famous in America I guess for
you know I guess when making people deep
throat slices of steak no saltfish
Turkish oh that's right so he goes to
the thing he looks Lionel Messi
solidified himself as the goat the
greatest of all time and it's not not
because of his seven bucks he blows him
off though he's like get out of here
it's his moment it's like Miss Martin
he's grabbed his elbow and mess he's
like okay you got your picture okay
that's so weird he's not having it it's
like get out of here yeah he's not
having it
I mean I would assume
this makes Messi the greatest ever do it
because right yeah Ronaldo Jesus look at
this guy because Ronaldo I went to that
restaurant by the way I tried free
mistake I wouldn't do it I won't let my
girl do it either I'm like no no no
you're not deep throating his sirloin
look at messy look but then he keeps
going on them and then he's like get out
of here dude
I mean
he's like yeah yeah very cool you're
Salt Bay I'm messy the most famous
athlete on the planet right get away
from me
I would assume this solidifies Messi is
the best ever do it because him and
Ronaldo is like one or two depends right
well Ronaldo's team didn't win it you
got it yes he did I assume you do I know
soccer well enough I probably sound like
your name what a swan song and he's not
even retired like no he's three times
that was his last game ever Messi was
that was this game what an incredible I
just finally retired okay well that's
fine I didn't know that that's fine did
he yeah it's fine he's not playing
that's it next year that's it that's why
it's a big but he's playing on such a
high level he's still doing it he's an
older dude he can still do it clearly I
gotta look into this
denying rumors of his retirement you
[ __ ]
oh I'm not gonna retire for the national
team why do you have to say things
because I want the drama I wanted to
draw no you were saying a little [ __ ]
Community
you don't know this see I want I want
the drums damn it you're about to cry
yeah it was I had a whole plan I set up
the announcer a lot of people are
careful he's only 35.
ah
oh you wish you had it I do what a way
to go out though what a way to go out
that's not getting better than that dude
because Chance you win it another four
years ain't good that's correct but I
think Brazil's ranked number one too I
mean I'm gonna wait for another four
years oh watch the women's
is this uh what I think this is made of
wood yeah the women's coming up is this
wood yeah no your sock trying to go to
the wins game
what is it that sign is made from the
that's Neon right and that's a gas for
the most part
kill the whims game though hey that that
Brittany grinder you're like we gotta
get her out cool go to a game bro show
the support by a jersey somebody said
somebody said do you know one other NBA
WNBA player just give me one more name
yeah I saw some kind of do a bit on it
and he goes for those of you mad at me
bring up this Brittney Griner thing name
the team she plays for he goes I'll wait
shut the [ __ ] up
on it
so good and then some woman was saying
uh Don Lemon had had something to say
too Don Lemon was like defending it
because this woman goes we need to put
more of the same resources in the end
WNBA is and and if we if if big media
and money put money behind it people
would watch WNBA and Don Lemon was going
that's just not true no he goes well the
women should be paid just as much she
goes the marketplace says no was the
voice of reason you know when that
happens now the only thing is with the
women uh soccer they're dominant and
they actually bring in more eyeballs
than the guys I think so now they've
made it almost equal pay because they
actually again it's market value the
women's soccer team generates viewership
so they get paid what they're worth they
generate viewership yeah not bring it
bring it up Jim again
U.S women's uh soccer viewership
compared to men's soccer yeah I mean I'd
love to see it but the men's I mean
especially this year it was big I feel
like we got into it
22 higher than the men's in 2018. wow
good for them I'm all for it then they
should get paid well yeah it's market
value and also 100 if WNBA views were
the same as NBA they would get equal pay
Thorns nobody nobody watches anything
but you know good for them
but nobody watches what women's soccer
or even Americans that's not true that's
not true in the World Cup they do no in
the world outside world cup no we don't
pay attention to I mean that MLS
[ __ ] and all that that's like
because you're giving us David Beckham
he's 55 with his nuts down his ankles
kicking [ __ ] yeah Corner kicks
he's still playing
no
so do you so this is Elizabeth Warren
yeah but this is a while ago because
they they got equal pay yeah so says the
US Women's is the number one in the
world and contributes higher revenues
for U.S soccer than the men's team but
they're still paid a fraction what the
men earn women deserve equal pay for
equal or better working offsets factors
and on soccer field no I think I think
if if the market they changed it no I'm
telling you they changed it yeah they
get paid now good
in Iran too women's soccer team psych oh
sorry I guess he's joining the women's
soccer
score 50 points what that kid can score
50 points oh yeah you just can't be out
here I went to a Black Rifle coffee and
did their podcast out in Salt Lake Matt
best hey hey cool stay home right not
too much right no I had a great time
Matt best and um and Evan Hafer love it
there's my boys guys and I and and uh
Evan made me a hell of a cup of coffee
well Evan's The Connoisseur that's more
of the face but Evan knows he was making
coffee in the yeah in the fox yeah and
Kevin and Evans right temperature Evan's
done some some stuff in the military
this and that I'll tell you Matt best
some nice stuff too is those tattoos and
he has a bullet that has like a 19x
what's the 19 stand for you I don't talk
about that one
I get it uh-huh well hey Matt I get it
Evan is Evan is such a great guy and
such a down-to-earth [ __ ] man
he's such a dog the companies with like
500 million they went public over a
billion yeah they were massive and they
started it nine years ago we were we
were there dude I had my own big brown
coffee with them yeah we've been with
them for a hot second yeah now they're
with um
they're in all the Dick's Sporting Goods
like they're massive massive they have
commercials I like to pick Evan's brand
because he's super smart about what the
real the real [ __ ] like the real tip of
the spear stuff all the all the all the
stuff everybody loves that yeah Black
Rifle gunship coffee yeah I have a
membership at all man I had I heard
something that kind of like like kind of
blew my mind like [ __ ] you know these
guys that we were talking on the podcast
about
you know how to deal with challenges in
life and all that stuff you know things
come up yeah sure and he goes um
standard pod talk and he goes uh
they had this guy who had been in the
military 21 years doing some [ __ ] you
understand 21 years it's not his final
to call it Black Ops yeah Black Ops like
that that heavy on the elite [ __ ] yeah
like there are divisions in the than the
sort of paramilitary CIA where they'll
be like here's ten dollars
you got to take three modes of
transportation and get from Paris to
like London go you're like what you know
[ __ ] like that so anyway he's he's on
his 20
first year last mission to win the most
dangerous [ __ ] gets hit by an IED his
legs get blown off luck would have it
legs get totally taken away last one he
said
[ __ ] it [ __ ] no he looks down and he
goes challenge accepted
and by the way it's killing it I'm sure
you know but but I mean well that's
what's great about I never thought I
never forgot that I was like yeah all
those guys everybody in that office is
most people are like veterans tip of
this not a lot of [ __ ] yes humble and
great everyone is to work there you have
to be a former uh love them yeah
military yeah then they then Evan just
gave uh his friend their two military
guys uh like a huge area right there for
where they forged knives Grizzly forger
and and another you make their knives
there yeah and they were great I mean
it's a great it's like you go there and
it's like a big family oh no I love
those guys God
um did you listen to David Goggins
speaking of motivational David Goggins
on you know not Dave Gunn's fan but I do
now the viewers who are just listening
the camera's gonna pick up on it I don't
like your attitude I didn't do anything
because he was a Navy SEAL I didn't say
anything when I said David guys
I didn't I want to be very clear with
the fans I did not say anything like
that about David Goggins no I just you
want him running to your house speaking
[ __ ] out of you no I was just thinking
about what's your problem this guy lost
his legs and then you're talking about
David Goggins who's does a lot of
running in it and felt that was a lot of
running just all the runs yeah David
Goggins I think was in a program in the
SEAL Teams where he was
um
what are you laughing Brian I'm thinking
about something else no you're not
why are you laughing I'm not what
program was he in adopted time I was
thinking about saying I was gonna make a
joke so David Goggins was actually I
think in a program the Navy Seals where
that where they take you and you
represent them in sports so you
represent them in triathlons you went
through buds though yeah but but I think
Goggins was not so much in uh to bring
that up to does David Goggins have is he
battle tested well I don't think I don't
think he's in combat I'm not saying who
you are a little bit let's let's see
what the computer says no the the before
you go bad on my friend David guy yes
because I'm a fan
deployed to Iraq Seal Team five ever
heard of it yeah the training instructor
with other seals David Goggins was a guy
who represents so the seals I think I've
heard this from other seals that he
represented the seals as a sort of an
ambassador in in in sport in triathlons
and stuff like that so he went through
all the program but I think rather than
be in combat no he was in combat no uh
maybe deployment tonight Seal Team five
as well certainly as training instructor
for other seals in 2005 during Operation
Red Wings in Afghanistan 12 nations were
killed in more engine and brutal
fighting so he so he's definitely yeah
some tour I don't know I I heard
something else but I don't know I don't
know anything about it I do yeah well
I'm sure I don't want to get into this
because I'm already in a I'm already in
a I don't want to sound like I'm dissing
anybody like and I don't know David
Goggins I don't know anything he left a
little bit I don't know I don't know
anything about it
the issue I'm having but what I
understand stood was that he had by
choice or that they took him and said
look you you're in this crazy shape you
love these triathlons represent us over
here and that's where he kind of spent
most of his time sure but either way
he's a badass yeah the thing about him
too though is uh and I thought you know
like uh the American Sniper guy was
named Kyle
Chris Kyle Chris Kyle right there seems
to be this thing too when these guys get
like uber famous of the other like not
all of them but few of them will try and
bring him down happened in comedy
happens a lot of things so Dave Goggins
right massively famous now yeah there
seems to be this narrative where people
try and tear it down it's just Society
it's what we do
um unfortunately so Dave Goggins I mean
I don't give a [ __ ] if you serve 10
tours or one tour for the guy to do what
he did and go through Buds and be an
outlier yeah like a like a mental like
that's what he says about I like what he
says about you you haven't listened on
Rogan it's yeah I have no no the new one
you said you did it you said you didn't
I didn't hear the last one okay but I
like I like what he says he was talking
about he he's very honest with himself
well of course journey and stuff you
know well I was thinking about like and
he's like I don't do other podcast like
he only does Rogan I don't want to talk
about him running I'm doing my [ __ ]
right right he's always competing with
himself but and he didn't have a
meniscus like they were like we can't
believe we ran let alone 200 miles she's
like doing all this [ __ ] like just men
simply just complete Savage like almost
a sociopath like the way he trains and
runs I'm like there's something like
there psycho yeah yeah
crazy like yeah like just cut from a
different clock he'll die yeah Cut From
a Different Cloth he says him and Kim
Haynes get together and they see who can
break who Damn and then he's like we're
still trying we've been friends for 10
years never been able to break each
other but they're just they did
15 miles to start and they did six
minute miles they averaged six minute
miles
get the F get out of here's my age and
he was saying cames he was like I know
this path he's like this for sure I'm
gonna break him he's like and I see him
Venture off somewhere and he's like oh I
broke him finally nope you're the
[ __ ] I thought you were
David and Kim not young how old is he I
want to find out how old he's got that's
crazy 50 it's my age how old is David
David's 47. Draco willink 51. just
Savages dude but I was thinking about it
for uh not that he needs money I'm sure
his books crush it and he's so
motivational you read another book he
wrote another one that's why he was
coming on Rogue for his book but uh
David Goggins I was thinking I'm like
man he could make so much money doing
motivational speaking and I was thinking
he does when I was a kid I don't know if
he's doing that but I'm like does he go
to a division like does he go to Ohio
state Alabama talk but that I was
hearing him talking like he's almost too
extreme right I don't know if these kids
can relate to it because he's such an
outlier amongst outliers like the stuff
he does is so insane yeah
you can book them
100 grand
yeah but he's like such an outlier
amongst outliers like
from what I heard I heard somebody on
podcast again I don't know [ __ ] about
Navy Seals clearly but they're saying he
was even disliked amongst the seals
because he was like such an outlier like
always talking [ __ ] like always trying
to break people and they were just like
like he wasn't one of the guys I guess
he was like an outlier amongst outliers
at buds can't like they didn't like it I
don't know yeah is that what he said and
he remembered that that's from his mouth
I think so and then he was also like 300
something pounds too yeah I read about
that nuts yeah I heard him talking about
that but I was like man I wonder if he'd
be good to talk like University of
Colorado or Alabama and then I was heard
him talking like he's almost too Savage
for this were these kids I'm like Jesus
Christ man yeah you know like we can't
relate to this well some people get
motivation from it and other people
don't it just depends on your person
because it but he also does a good job
right now he's like
because they're asking Romans asked
about failures he's like I fail all the
time but I don't call it failures are
called attempts so I position my mind
where it's an attempt not a failure it's
an attempt so I'm attempting eventually
I'm gonna get it might take me six
attempts but they're not failures
because I'm I'm gauging till I get it
it's an attempt I find it motivational
just because he's such an outlier for me
that that's not I I've never gelled with
that like my so some kids like that'll
work on on some people and the kind of
people it works on are people that go
into the military or like the certain
jobs that that requires and I'm not
saying it's not without value for
everybody but then there are people that
that that's not as motivated oh I don't
think he's for everybody no he's such an
outlier yeah that's what I'm saying he's
such an hour I don't think you'd work
with a lot like when I was in college
now I like like when I would get
um energy or I would get motivations
from seeing others break yeah so so I
can share that comment but some people
mind with him you know like I'm sure a
guy like Lawrence Vickers or someone
like that Lauren the same like Savage
yeah you're gonna there's a few guys on
the team who are savages like that like
they like to train that hard get into
the nitty-gritty they see people break
whoever lasts they can trust them Dave
is the same way so I think some guys
might connect with it but the majority
of the team wouldn't probably shut them
down because he's such an outlier like
when he's talking about there he was
like some days I'll I'll say hey just
around 10 miles and then I get 10 miles
and he goes and I think to myself and
that's where I think you know psychopath
comes in he goes there's some
[ __ ] out there running 15 15
miles I'm only doing 10. so I run 15.
now you get to 15. I think there's some
[ __ ] I have to run 18 so I run
18. you're like holy [ __ ] dude yes
when's enough enough yeah that's and
then he goes people ask me what I'm
getting ready for it was nothing I'm
getting ready for when I don't need to
be because you never know when it's
going to come in my head I'm like well
what the [ __ ] is coming where you're
gonna have to run 20 miles at six minute
miles yeah what is coming because if
that's what gets you out of it the rest
of us are [ __ ] life life just getting
ready for yeah for him it's more getting
comfortable in pain
yeah I mean if you could put his brain
in a robot we're all [ __ ] he just
doesn't can't stop won't stop yeah and
then Rogan's goes you take vacations
remembers I take vacations he's [ __ ]
no I don't take no vacations because I
have many vacations when I'm eating
lunch vacation I'm having food it's a
vacation I lay down for an application
Romans like yeah uh you can tell
everyone he's like yeah I get that um
yeah no kids are our wife no I think
he's a girl but Roman goes for creative
though it's good for me to reset and you
know and Damian's like yeah you can see
he was not like he was so funny when he
said some people call me they go you
over train he goes delete block delete
man you're betraying you're gonna hurt
yourself delete I get many vacations
Rogan loves that stop Rogan loves that
extreme outliers it's an extreme extreme
outlier yeah me and Joe talked today we
had a conversation about Peter Zion who
I had on my podcast uh
um the global strategist oh you sent me
a clip of them right yeah watch that
yeah watch that because you know so so
it's not that's not yeah they're in seon
when when uh it's it's spelled
z-e-i-h-a-n and and he wrote this
amazing book that I'm reading now at the
end of the world is just the beginning
oh you told me about it people who think
that uh there are a couple things people
think that China is going to take over
the world that's adorable yeah you told
us on the last Pond yeah because they
import so agriculture is the biggest
challenge when you want so so when you
grow food you need guess what fossil
fuels why because uh nitrogen which is
what how you get fertilizer in the
ground phosphates and things like that
you need oil for that the the compounds
for all fertilizer is oil for for
pesticides is oil herbicides oil and on
top of that when you want to irrigate
you know what irrigating is when you
gotta pump water in your crust you need
you need a an engine for that sir
correct so and that runs really adorable
what's adorable is when people think
that we're going to have electric cars
and that's going to be the only things
and I told you this and also that that
electricity is going to run our economy
that's adorable adorable if you just
look into it it's not sustainable but do
you know you know Cobalt you need what
you get from the Congo and how much
lithium which is you need a cold grid to
so my my Tesla my Tesla is already when
I buy it already piece of [ __ ] it's in
at Ford F-150 on the road for 55 000
miles already correct which I didn't
know oh yeah yeah yeah yeah education
and and so you're not getting you're not
getting electric cars without all the
fossil fuels correct but also you know
fossil fuels because we're taught this
in high school yeah or I'm sorry even
Middle School fossil fuels remember they
said it was dinosaurs came from
dinosaurs or not you know that was a
marking scheme by an oil guy I in like
the 30s sure that they came up with this
concept they hey say it's scarce say the
scarcity of oil came from dinosaurs and
we'll run out of it
American never run out of water no we
got hey we're never running it doesn't
come from dinosaurs hey it doesn't come
from dinosaurs that was a marketing Ploy
that was very well done in order to
boost the sale of oil yeah I don't think
I don't think I ever thought it was
dinosaurs but well that's what they
taught in school yeah and so that we're
going to run out but it was a marketing
plan back saying that word that it's
scarcity we're gonna run out because it
came from dinosaur Sands are everything
shell like that's what we that's what we
are an energy independent
but it's it's fascinating man yeah no
it's hilarious that uh people think that
when you listen to him talk and you know
what's I would educate him on dinosaurs
the biggest thing right the biggest
threat is dumbass right is right no no
man I went hey
you think dinosaurs you think the only
thing of oil dumbass yeah well he got
into the uh Russian war
Rush is there and he said it's not gonna
be over for a hot second oh dude because
Russia that's almost a fight for their
survival they're existential they're the
ones that signed up for it but here's
the thing we all need Russia and that's
the other thing they're not talking
about hit their oil this is where you
learn oil their oil
we need it Germany is already
de-industrializing like because they get
80 of their oil from the pipeline we
need oil from Russia and not only that
we get our
potash
do you know what pot ashes
yeah glad you asked no bring up potash
and bring up where we get 70 of our
you're not growing crops it's gonna be
Russia let me search that just spray
Upon Us yeah so potash is you need it I
guess so it contains potassium water
soluble uh potash comes from either
underground you need it from uh for for
growing crops it's insanely important
and go down on the right where it says
potash it says uh what is potash used
for click on that yeah potash is
primarily in fertilizers approximately
95 to support plant growth increase crop
yield yeah disease resistant now it's
waterproof I believe 70 comes from
Russia the other part comes from Ukraine
and we can't make it here no it's not in
it's not it's it's already there we
could try to figure it out we're gonna
have to figure out how to make it there
but right now uh it's estimated at 79
tons
okay we're friends we're good hey we're
good three coaches Canada Russia and
Belarus accounted for 70 of the world's
potash yeah but we can steal the counter
Canada ain't enough the world needs well
Russia and China is the world's largest
potash sounds like a friend now oh
Armageddon and then Canada's no no good
Canada only accounts for 31 of the
world's total we need the other yeah
there's a little [ __ ] in the argument
there no they account for 70 right but
right
get the other 50 they they provide 50
yeah but Canada where was putting this
weekend Belarus he died interesting he
died he went to Belarus and so they say
I guess we believe that right
so we get our most we get it mostly from
Canada most of the phosphates are grown
in China China so Russian builders
provide 12 uh used in the U.S the
American depends on nitrogen phosphates
and part is much smaller 12. we can grow
our own food we're [ __ ] luck Canada
provides 83 of the potash used in the
U.S how about that so we need them hey
so we don't need rush orbelers we don't
care no no we're good United States is
good 100 all the way around energy
Independence I know well but I'm saying
if you're China and you important you
import 80 of everything you need just to
grow food they're looking at famine oh
it's a disaster Chinese problem though
yeah it's Chinese problem but anybody in
America you speak American right huh you
speak American right no I do dude I'm
just saying South America Mexico is
going to be great we take care of our
own South America Mexico United States
all good Australia all good England has
a deal with America that's going to be
all good because that brexit wasn't good
those are the places that tour I'm sorry
where's this Brandon's prom uh well now
now Germany is going to de-industrialize
Germany is in serious trouble because
they again have to they're banking on
Russia all their [ __ ] fuel okay
uh the Chinese they have to import all
the fuel they don't have navies
they don't have navies so that when a
Russian oil ship gets hijacked when it
gets jacked it causes major problems
he was going through how the world is
breaking apart and it was hoping it's a
better argument than yours well the
world around the world is looking at
famine possibly in the next five years
that's what someone else was terrifying
yeah because you don't realize what goes
into all the minerals we need all those
we got a problem like we got problems
here in America you like your phone
Cobalt get a half an ounce of cobalt in
there but there it comes from very few
places they get a mind for it well you
got it you got to get kids to mine it in
the Congo that's what goes on but you
guys want to ban Tesla right yeah
Tesla's the you know what he said you
know what Peterson said he said he goes
Zion said he said look here's you want
to know why your country is doing
amazing why the United States is doing
amazing because we squibble we squibble
over culture War things like gender
neutral that's when you know things are
good it's when you know things are great
if they're looking at how they're going
to grow no yeah debating over uh
pronouns stuff like that that's like
arguing that the the window on your
Penthouse is too small not good you know
hey are you American right because you
keep I'm confused you American right I'm
just I'm just confused you're American
you American yeah bro I'm just this
podcast you still in communist no no
because we brought up the US men's team
and you said they don't speak English no
I just started there and I was like oh
that's strange I can explain and then
you went on this
right now from this brain guy I'm just
that we need to be worried about things
and we said we I thought you meant
Americans are you American right and I
went well that makes sense because we're
getting our potash from Canada 83 of it
yeah you went no I'm talking about China
be American no I am huh so what do we
care what they do we're talking about
the Chinese starvation what do we care
but we care I'm just saying that hey let
me just I'm a global citizen sure that's
how I want to solve this
USA men's basketball team plays China
who are you rooting for I'm rooting for
America
I'm like
You Got Me Wrong bro I'm American
you see keep going by the tones
by the Days of Our Lives I knew it I
know Communists
[ __ ] up dice
you worried about what what press Court
defense China can play over here I don't
give a [ __ ] no you know what it sounds
like what trying to prom no hide this
job you know what I'm gonna do this what
I'm watching LeBron put his big black
dick in the face no it's kind of guys
when you've done something no I know
China hey hey
how's that Yao Ming Jersey doing man I'm
not wearing that [ __ ] bro I don't have
one I know
I'm wearing one I got Damon little
Jersey be cool man literally be cool
Lily I'm American American it doesn't
sound like you no you arguing for the
team I always said Black Rifle wait for
that podcast coming out Brian Campbell
no not to hear this Communists no please
and they went bad and Dave got you oh no
I'm gonna add that in here you can go
bad on Goggins that's right you abandon
the US men's soccer team no you said
they're all oh they're not even from
here
there you go keep doubling down
that's all I said keep digging that hole
to China come on you go bad on US men's
soccer team you're bad on
the mascot for America Dave nice he
didn't go back at him he went on I like
David no I just
I was talking about the guy who had no
legs I thought that was like bad taste
you about you you're a soccer team Dave
Goggins I'm so worried we're out of hate
ass with the [ __ ] hot ass man yeah he
that's Berry potassium I hate assbury in
San Francisco no get it correct
I can't sleep at night that's not a
problem
it's a Child Problem
look it's not a problem now listen
I mean [ __ ]
damn it
all right Tim what do you got get me out
of this room with this goddamn communist
[ __ ] uh do you guys want to see Gordon
Ryan rolling with Thor for a little bit
it's already okay yeah I saw it I took
it all in what I expected
what'd you think by the way by the way
Gordon Ryan's so much bigger than me and
look at how much smaller he is wow that
throwing me seriously it's very close
now just to be clear Glenn Ryan would do
that to me as well
maybe not as easily because I know those
sweeps and stuff but he would roll me
like a goddamn I think
he'd roll me up like well you know a lot
of what he's gonna do but he is I speak
the language right yeah but I'm I'm the
foreign
all day
he could talk to him any way he wanted
he is so [ __ ] good man
God
all right Brian your boy Zion
uh
dude you're just all over guys no legs I
am that's your thing I am today no in
general it's your face how'd it go watch
the guy you want him right in the face
he won by unanimous decision
[Music]
tough for that guy nobody's cheering for
the guy with full capabilities
right
you guys just the worst takedown defense
in the world
did you get the full amount
well I mean
those grappling's nice I bet he's so
strong dude I've never felt that on his
shoulder oh he's on bottom now I never
felt anybody stronger all the guys on
Mount full mount
right he's always found right yeah
that's correct bad joke yeah there's
always something else yeah that's
inspiring dude that's a badass but I
would assume like if one Championship
offers him like heart check please out
head kicks how did our boys Strickland
do
sorry
I didn't watch it you lost me a decision
he did born fight he was a little
hesitant
just it's more of a matter of
um Canon air it's just he just makes he
makes guys look porn like he did with
Izzy yeah he's just you know he's timid
you know like you guys become timid
against them but he won the fight I
thought he won 48-47 they get the judge
had uh uh 49 uh what 49 46 two for
Canada one for uh Strickland
uh so this guy put Love Sean but you
can't act like a lion and fight like a
cat SOB fight crazy scorecards economy
and judge and 49-46 one person four nine
four six the other person too subjective
and opinionated can we get a real
scoring system that's the Doug Crosby
stuff yes yeah weird one wow
anyways
yeah
okay
well
uh who else for Strickland yeah
there's a little bit of an update on the
twitch thing this is mind-blowing very
sad me too and I've never met the guy
I've always been a family he looks so
happy yeah my family's gorgeous three
kids my girl would always tell me she's
good it's a perfect family oh my God and
they were well it just goes to show you
like social media I tell people this all
the time ain't real it's people posting
15 second videos maybe 45 seconds videos
in their entire day and we assume that
they're doing okay it social media is
not real
he was clearly hurting like a mother
trucker I feel so sad that he did this
and how how he went to uh in Encino
close to us went to close to me went to
a hotel a mile away from his house put
his phone on silent mode and then blew
his head off
he shot himself in the chest I think
but what
um I I don't understand and then
apparently he left uh you leave your
children and then I saw some guy again
I'm sure this is all hearsay but they
they're saying that maybe he had money
troubles because he put all like his
life savings yeah crypto or something
not true oh they're saying put it in the
crypto or something but that's not a
reason to blow your house when you got
three kids right now apparently that
wasn't true too I think he just suffered
from real depression
but I mean that's like so that's where
you realize how serious mental health
serious mental health is like you know
like
I I told you
um a fan of mine who I you know I just
talked to him and he brought me a gift
after a show and um
he said I was talking about suicide and
I've told you this story before and he
said if you brought it up yeah on the
podcast and he emailed me and he said if
you want to know what it's like maybe
this can help you for somebody who has
tried to kill himself which was him
he said if you've ever been in a sauna
uh and it gets so hot you have to get
out think about being an Asana all the
time but there's no door
and I and I went I got it I went I can't
imagine that kind of discomfort despair
Panic now imagine twitch you're in that
sauna and you have three little kids who
depend on you it must have been so bad
and you know it's gonna [ __ ] you know
it's gonna [ __ ] those kids up the rest
of their life their daddy goes away and
they're young kids that's what I mean
and you can't apply reason to it so when
we say oh I can't believe we left this
kid you don't until you've been in that
desperate despair because you and I
don't suffer from that Chronicle illness
we've all you and I have been depressed
we have some dark times but we come out
of it now imagine you can't no matter
what no matter what in your life I told
you one of my [ __ ] favorite people a
really smart Pete person and and we were
talking and uh I said I I can't imagine
killing myself I said have you ever
thought about that and you know what he
goes he goes like this he goes all the
time
and I went what and that's his struggle
daily
yeah I have a buddy like that yeah every
day yeah every day it crosses his mind
we're so lucky don't deal with that I
know every single day man I know I mean
we're a family member who is that way
for a while and uh she was
she was uh drug saved her life uh
antidepressants saved her life oh yeah
so it worked you know but I I have I
have tremendous uh respect for anybody
who works in the mental health field
because it's obviously something I know
nothing about but it's obviously such a
[ __ ] well have you ever sat down with a
therapist be like one-on-one or just
family when you sit down they'll ask you
like when you're going through things
like first thing I said we thought about
killing yourself I'm like nope like all
right let's continue if you do yeah
wouldn't you threaten that then then
they start calling in some Big Boys well
when I did the Black Rifle podcast Evan
those guys deal with suicide all the
time PTSD yeah and um one of the things
that Evan said was like you know two of
his friends recently and uh he said it
just comes out of nowhere though like
it'll come out of nowhere they're doing
great and then
you know your kids go off to school and
just go out in the backyard and treat
yourself that's an illness yeah straight
illness that we can't comprehend but I
think with science and you know it's
technology advances when I look back I'm
like Jesus the amount of [ __ ] that
whatever you got to do right micro
dosing helps people apparently some
people depending who knows obviously not
everybody otherwise we wouldn't have a
problem it's that easy you're right no I
don't think it's like it's not again you
know I've dealt with my entire life I
won't get into it and then also I've had
close friends and co-workers who deal
with it and it's tough to understand
you're like come on dude and when
they're having a bad day
it's the worst day like literally that's
the worst day of their life that's right
and there's no being funny there's no
being silly there's not nothing in
children nothing hey man remember that
time we did yeah you're like oh come not
that that works on me but I don't suffer
from what they I don't speak to it you
know it is I don't speak their language
yeah I wish I did I wish I could help
and then you and I was talking about
this this is how naive we are about
suicide and stuff like that is I'm
always like man if I could just talk to
them guarantee I've talked them out of
it nope you [ __ ] [ __ ] too the same
as store thing you could roll with Ryan
Gordon you know you and I go and we can
talk I tried that with my friend uh when
I was younger he said I'm gonna go away
uh and I want to give you my record
collection and I was like what are you
talking about and I realized he was
going to kill himself and I go and I
[ __ ] I remember saying that I'm
[ __ ] so lame I go but I didn't know
what to do I go but your brother had
twins so that's good right and he goes
yeah I go so there you go you have a
reason you know but that but that would
work for us yeah but you know it's not
it's not your ball like it works it'd
work on you and me yeah but we don't
suffer from that illness you know it's
such a shame
we it's like you suffer from depression
like you don't have the cold someone
comes up with stage five cancer and they
have three days to live and it's going
well I use NyQuil man that should help
right yeah no dumbass different sickness
yeah and he was uh also smarter than I
was so I couldn't I didn't have it I
didn't have anything else thank you yeah
I'm like oh never mind talk to him about
uh whatever the fossil fuels was I was
gonna see all that because I was by the
way he could be Chinese and you could be
looking at famine in 10 years you know
what I'm saying that might have got them
out there but it doesn't work
no but I had like a period when I was
you know I couldn't explain yeah
everything you look in the mirror and
you're so [ __ ] good looking yeah yeah
but chin you had a period but it was
just it was because career-wise it
wasn't going good no no no I do remember
I told you at this on shop show I had
taken like cough syrup but too much of
it and I had this huge crazy panic
attack yeah and then since that moment I
never really recovered until like three
or four years later
like hardcore things like NyQuil damn
like anxiety you know we have a really
bad feeling like yeah something like
yeah something's wrong with your kid or
something yeah a few nights a week it
just wouldn't go away I'm like what the
hell and it lasted for years it lasted
for a long time you took night like
night time Robitussin and then if you
look online people purposely take
Robitussin like oh a ton to you know
[Music]
mine was like physical though action
Jesus have you seen action G take it
easy dude you're a communist and you're
preaching religion are you trying to
ruin your career well have you seen is
that what you're doing because you're
doing a fine job at it wow no I'm
kidding have you seen action Jesus I
have he's great
um hey man no I have action but but chin
there's uh when those like NyQuil and
Robitussin the nighttime things yeah I
don't know what's and I'd rather deal
with the sickness because I took it last
week on Monday yeah for the shop show my
brain was so far
oh yeah thank God I didn't have stand up
or I was on Rogan or something I was
underwater like you're in a plane and
your ears oh dude I took everything to
get up nothing could shake the cobwebs I
know exactly I was like what the [ __ ]
I'd rather be sick than this over the
counter too then it's not stupid I don't
know what's in there it's that dimethyl
something man
and you don't feel well like yeah you
get sleep but it can't be quality sleep
yeah
uh can I just see uh action Jesus just
for me the extra more yeah whatever that
is uh action what action Jesus bro
action Jesus
see you don't know what this is and I've
seen them look at that right sir these
are big big this is big money just
images yeah they got all these they got
all these like you can buy all these
things where he's like
areas all muscle I don't want to root
for your kid that's what you got for
Christmas isn't it it's Jesus who's
really muscular you know what it is it's
He-Man but comes with a cross yeah and
you got a sword there but it's like a
cross yeah yeah a T-man but with a cross
yeah yeah I don't that's kind of not the
point of action G is G is supposed to
turn the other cheek and love his Enemy
No this Jesus [ __ ] people up yeah look
at that right there that's look at that
the action Jesus wow that's for the
hardcore religious who are also into
violence you got fish
you got his hands different hands where
he's being like you can replace his
hands he has like a thing like like the
you can change his head with a Halo
Crown of Thorns oh dude I forgot I took
uh my son don't do this and you probably
know this your kids are older I took my
son C Avatar too last night how was it
not for little kids hours and 40 minutes
long oh boy two hours in I'm like oh my
god oh and then finally the waiter came
out hey how long is the one who goes
right it's about 3 40. excuse me three
hours 40 minutes I don't do anything for
three hours
yeah sure all that [ __ ] dude
after two hours we just walked out
really tell you guys I'm good I go I'm
good buddy but I'm good but but then we
watched in the world you know the plot
people love it and the the graphics are
cool I thought it was better than the
first one people are obsessed with it so
I make some Flack for this I thought the
storyline sucked it was nowhere near as
gives the first one then that water
world thing because I thought the first
ones had a good storyline personally
yeah it's FernGully whatever they stole
the idea but it was a good story this
one no one it just was right into it
like I guess everybody's blue now
wow I was just kind of bored people
people love it maybe I was I was more
stressed because my son I was like three
hours and 40 minutes and they can swim
underwater and breathe uh the the actual
water ones can they they get hold their
breath
whatever but then watch it yeah you
should people I love mushrooms though
sure sure and bring your action Jesus
figurine there because I left we walked
I go to I go to a toy store at the mall
here I'm with my son we're getting his
brother a gift I walk in the store this
toy store they have real swords on the
wall
straight up Samurai long [ __ ] swords
the ones that from like [ __ ]
the movies like big giant real legit
swords and my my son goes down they have
swords that's a great [ __ ] question
so I'm ringing out that boxing a little
car he likes Bugatti so I found this
Bugatti car for a Christmas for him
hopefully he doesn't listen to this and
I go uh I go hey man uh it's a kid's toy
store right he goes yeah why do you sell
swords and is there a legal age only 21
or older I go
do you sell many women because a lot of
adults buy those men we have a lot of
adult fans in here and kids yeah I was
like
is buying a sword they want a real sword
it's weird right yeah still can't carry
a sword which is [ __ ] all right uh
three hours and 12 minutes
um oh no but including the previews
which are 30 minutes three hours three
hours and 42 minutes I can't I want to
watch it but I'm gonna have to be very
high three hours and 40 minutes I don't
do anything for throughout no name
there's not a single thing I want to do
on this planet did you wear this the uh
yeah dude I did the whole thing are you
telling me shut up about it yeah it's
the IMAX yeah yeah sure dude yeah I'm
gonna go you know you should people
absolutely love it look 94
I kept walking out with your kids I
didn't think it was good as the first
one yeah I thought the storyline sucked
I'll probably just fall in love with it
and just not be the same after I see it
like chin with cough syrup all right um
chin got depressed after seeing the
first after I remember the Avatar Blues
people were committed suicide because
they can't live in Avatar I got a little
Avatar bluesy I'm gonna probably get
this too
what else you got Jen let me see what
this is I'm not sure oh no this is not
well let's look through this apparently
some people are saying this is real and
this is uh holocausta accidentally
hitting up the wrong people on I think
Facebook Messenger so I'm not saying
this is legit but this is Chris Weidman
and he goes are you still your dad's boy
and this is Nate Diaz you really think
you have a chance against shimov he's
going to use you as a punching bag like
everyone else and he goes wrong neatly
as LOL and look at the look at the
avatars
happy birthday bro
he's probably doing it as a joke like he
knows it's not them or someone Photoshop
this
I know I think this has to be
screenshots of him doing it so I don't
know
and this is Jake Paul I just thought it
was silly yeah but bro you got the wrong
guy LMAO I'm older than the other Jake
Paul signed the contract
apparently too Paulo Casas supposed to
fight Whitaker uh on the February 12th
card in Australia yep he tweeted that uh
Whitaker today was like Hey man they're
not paying me enough I'm not this is
fake news I didn't agree to this fight
I'm not fighting you who said that Costa
the guy we're talking about of course
yeah he was like that's all fake news he
said I'm not signed the contract unless
they pay more it ain't happening I'm
done
I'm done that's what he said he goes I'm
done
it says out about is off
yeah because he didn't agree to it
I'm very happy with that but Costa is my
favorite body in the UFC best body right
now yeah for sure
yeah currently yeah yeah nicest hits the
whole thing yeah whole thing popping
yeah he's hilarious too he told wicker
because workers did an interview talking
about the fight and he jumped on I was
like I ain't fighting you man like I
told him they have to pay me out they're
doing this is a troll job I never agreed
to this fight dude oh let's see the OJ
thing okay
so OJ was on
the full sun podcast with the note boys
and then this is basically a rumor
that's been going on forever we talked
about it many times that he's Chloe's
dad he denies that but he did say that
there's someone like
uh was it a pool person or something
Marcus Allen he goes
oh a cook a rumor that I was a cook that
potentially that could have been her dad
and not actual you know just because she
doesn't look like the other ones yeah so
OJ is making the podcast round yeah so
we're talking about what dude we should
do a uh uh um
uh
you know should we have O.J Simpson yes
or no poll yeah see what the fans that's
actually good now you know if he comes
on murders out of the question do I have
my black belt and O.J Simpson murder
trial I do be I do but you can't can't
talk about it yeah
he won't answer the questions oh no he
walked out you're bringing that up so
you got to talk about football any
regrets in life
uh
do you like the new Broncos right
um I'm not asking him those it's a it's
a interesting football like the state of
football today CT
it'd make I'd have him on one shoe yeah
I would have Mom I mean he's he's
historical I mean I'd be very interested
to talk he was found innocent well I
would be very interested in court of law
Brian asking him about just the world he
came out was different about what he
went in when he went out we know he
knows you know his dad was gay I didn't
know that yeah one of the reasons that
he had a lot of rage
how do you feel about USC how about how
do you feel about uh these players in
college getting paid now how much would
he have made compared to the players
today should Reggie Butch get his
Heisman back because he took pay and now
it's legal shouldn't they give it back
yeah like with SC they erased all zc
records they're racing all his [ __ ] from
SC even though he's found innocent
yeah we'd have to uh you still run with
the same Posse we have to ask what's
your favorite knives you know it's cool
questions like this
I think the poll is a great idea though
for the fans yeah yeah the Army well
maybe the fans can come up with
questions too
oh yeah you know we have that segment
back
fan questions with OJ what's funny about
this world we're living Bubba is that
like he if he does this right he'll
probably he either the Curiosity goes
away or he could turn into something
where he's making money again you know
it's it's very it's very weird what do
you mean
just when you're that relevant or when
how are you relevant how long do you
stay relevant you know those questions
well yeah he could well it's kind of
like the mafia guys right like we had
Sammy the bull on it legit sociopath
murder straight up however you want to
call it murdered many people
but now he has a platform because we
idolize the mafia and he's telling these
inside stories even though we know he
physically killed people
100 he did yeah killed people he talks
about it but people are okay with that
right because I guess they were also in
the business yeah and with OJ yeah
there's a wave of
I don't say redemption but there's a way
we have income if you start a YouTube
podcast getting into uh killings
yeah you know and then also I know
killed two people but he knows football
like a [ __ ] dude wrestler 2000
yards for Buffalo Bills football so even
breaking down football picks like a
podcast where you know football picks
you know or him doing like uh uh
straight up crime drama like narrative
there's something there someone's gonna
take a shot on him yeah I know thick boy
is okay I don't know would I yeah
if you'll be cool about it
you have to pay him a hefty fine though
a lot of money a lot of money
would uh true crime drama OJ it doesn't
matter if you had the downloads you
figure out and the money you'd make off
YouTube yeah there's gonna be some spots
that jumps on board because again he was
found innocent in the court of law
despite the popular opinion yeah it was
found guilty in Civil Court been the big
boy Court
innocent so you know who knows I
guarantee you there's some sponsors out
there who [ __ ] with them you'd make
money off them
about the time I'd put I you know maybe
I don't know
interesting and all the theories yeah
it'd be and he won't talk about it'd be
fun to have mine and go through the
different theories of the death
have I driven by the murder site yes
every year on the anniversary okay
have you ever read all the books yes I
have you're up on it yeah I love it that
stuff's so interesting to me yeah
a lot of fingers point at his oldest son
okay
I'll throw that out here
yeah
[Music]
real anger issue
something to think about something to
think about kids
um
yeah yeah I'd have them on yeah
all right you see what the fans say I'm
so curious to see what they say have you
guys seen this video yet no okay so this
is a guy that's doing a and you know a
voiceover of it like comedian but the
actual video is pretty awesome so it's a
Mexican bull rider and then this guy
will go ahead and talk
where he just got half smoking any of
the cast on
he's looking like he just left a
Nicaragua in prison looking to pound all
the pools give us that away
he's gonna write a book check him out
better than
look at him right
questions and breaking all sorts of
physics
what a bad [ __ ] and this from
Superstar comedy I don't know anything
about this but the video looks dope and
he might have been do you think he's
tied to it no no he just has he's been
doing that forever and he's just he's
just special and he rode that bull to
that bull calm the [ __ ] down and got
tired that's what he did and that's
called breaking a ball see what a battle
shut up all right and he kept it in
there he kept the cigarette there the
whole time cast on that's a bad
[ __ ] with a cast now come on man
come on um have you guys seen this video
it's an Elf on the Shelf someone sent
this in this is great okay I'll just
play for you no I haven't seen it
how about that
wow
why did you do that to me
why did you do that to me
he's so cute
ah no no it's not funny I've got school
that's funny yeah
this pants really went over Christmas is
the greatest thing in the world when
you're little
yeah it's kind of a bummer when you get
older right yeah you're like all right
actually this last one this was pretty
cool so when Qatar played the World Cup
they I don't know exactly what specific
buildings these are but they put um
khabib and his dad on the buildings I
thought that was Piers Morgan could be
pretty [ __ ] cool don't like Pierce
Morgan for a second
I think how big of a freaking celebrity
he is out there man my God
buddy Venice California
December 27th the Venice West I was on
the fence I decided I'm gonna do a show
why not get your tickets the Venice West
Venice California 17-17 Lincoln
Boulevard is the theater
briancallen.com for tickets Boston
Massachusetts
December 29 30 31 New Year's bringing it
in at last Boston one of my favorite
clubs San Diego comedy club right after
that I don't give a [ __ ] January 5 6 and
7. that's what I said yeah the weekend
after New Year's that's how I roll I
don't care Fort Wayne Indiana Summit
Comedy Club January 1314 Danny of
Florida Danny improv January 19 20 21
and then I got Nashville Tennessee
Zanies March 2 3 and 4. February New
York yeah so I take favor off or not
yeah I got I got one date in at the
comic strip uh in Edmonton actually
first time in Canada in a long time hot
second yeah uh and just coming in hot we
just agreed to it the this morning
refresh that chin
Las Vegas
I'm in Wise Guys Las Vegas your boy
opened the club about a year and a half
ago I am back all new hour January 5th
through January 7th Wise Guys Las Vegas
Nevada that's for the locals the Vegas
locals okay I'm like me next to Celine
Dion All right but uh January 5th
through the 7th Las Vegas first stop in
2023 come get some Vegas and then uh
January end of January January 20th
through 21st I'm Tampa Tampa Bay Florida
at Tampa Improv Springfield Missouri is
February 3rd through the 4th Naples
February 16th and 18th there's a bunch
of other cities on there but 2023 is
getting juicy but we're taking the 2023
year off in Las Vegas Nevada Wise Guys
tickets just went on sale right now at 2
20 p.m let's sell these [ __ ] out
Thursday Friday Saturday Las Vegas
Nevada the whole thick boy Squad will be
there
fatkz.com or thickboy.com get you some
I'm excited man all right kids we love
you see ya God bless fine kid we're out
merry Christmas happy holidays